what are you noticing though about some
of the young people what they're doing
how they're feeling about fatigue
lockdown yeah you know when i spoke with
dr fauci earlier this year he mentioned
that it's not abnormal for young people
to be responsible for the spread of
infectious disease so this isn't
i don't mean to sound like a boomer with
that blaming young people but it isn't
super rare for young people to spread
infectious disease a lot uh but what is
interesting particularly in the us is
that young people just aren't getting
vaccinated at the rates that we had
anticipated and that public health
experts had anticipated for those 18 to
24 year olds only 56 percent of them are
vaccinated right now and that's just not
high enough right is there an issue
though with them being young meaning
physiologically is there an issue with
them maybe being more susceptible to
both getting the virus as well as
transmitting it you know what's so
interesting about that question is that
in the beginning we thought that it was
older individuals we were worried about
the 65 plus immunocompromised folks but
the virus is so smart and it wants to
stay alive so as that older group got
vaccinated the virus said okay well i
guess i'm going to have to go to the
younger people now if i want to survive
but when you look at those vaccination
rates that we had on the screen i mean
it shows you part of the problem is this
just an issue of age of people just i
guess at a certain demographic just say
i don't need to worry i mean when i was
18 and 24 i didn't really care about
anything right well and also you're
thinking to yourself in this position
i've had to take a year off of college
i'm trying to go out with my friends
right and you've been hearing from
experts that the virus isn't going to
make you super sick so they didn't know
that they needed to really go out and
get this vaccine
and feel a lot of pressure about that
and now they not only need to be
vaccinated they also need to get these
booster shots so it's a big big push for
uh public health officials to get these
younger individuals to go get those jabs
all right a very important stuff here uh
madison mills from bloomberg quick take
stopping by here to give us a little bit
of insight into that aspect of this